active 6 a 10 este es facturado en un
tweet lo anuncio donald trump dijo esta
noche la primera dama y yo hemos dado
positivo en el test de kobe 19
comenzaremos nuestro proceso de
cuarentena y recuperación inmediatamente
pasaremos esto juntos la noticia llega
después de que job ix una de las
asesoras más cercanas al presidente
reveló síntomas y dio positivo de
coronavirus ella viajó con el presidente
varias veces esta semana a bordo del air
force one y fue vista cerca de otros
funcionarios de la campaña durante un
mitin en pensilvania el sábado sin
llevar mascarilla en un comunicado de la
casa blanca el médico personal de trump
sound conley dijo el presidente y la
primera dama están bien en este momento
y planean permanecer en la casa blanca
durante su convalecencia espero que el
presidente continúe cumpliendo con sus
deberes sin interrupciones mientras se
recupera
después de conocer sus resultados
positivos el presidente trump dijo que
él y la primera dama se aislaría pero no
dijo por cuánto tiempo la primera dama
dijo en twitter que ella y el presidente
se sentían bien y que ella había
aplazado sus próximos compromisos el
vice presidente mike pence dijo que
rezaba por la rápida recuperación de la
primera pareja vuelva menospreciado
constantemente la gravedad de la crisis
sanitaria que ha matado a más de 200.000
estadounidenses hasta ahora a los 74
años y con sobrepeso trump está en un
grupo vulnerable para los que contraen
el virus la noticia ha lanzado una nueva
incertidumbre en la recta final que
conduce a la elección presidencial con
mítines y debates previstos en los
próximos días y semanas